all right so we talked about separable
filters and the nice thing about
separable filters is that they're
incredibly quick and this means that for
example in computer games you could
actually do some of this on the graphics
card at 60 frames a second right these
are the kind of things that people who
are writing computer games not me people
who know what they're doing well I think
if you the games are thinking about
right how can we do post processing like
motion blur and bloom and other kinds of
filters that look good in a game but
don't drive the whole thing to a halt
separable filters are a great way of
doing this the problem is that Gaussian
blur which is the thing we kind of
focused on doesn't look that good as a
blur right if you say well I want to do
some depth of field I want to do some
optical depth of field all right so I
want the foreground person in my game to
be nice and sharp and I want the
background to be lovely blur right it
will look a bit odd if you use a
Gaussian because that's not what a lens
does you need to use a proper spoke a
blur I don't know how you pronounce that
where bouquet is right bouquet right
bokeh bouquet oh yeah I lost interest
it's because of the way that the optics
of a camera work right so a Gaussian
your point is spread over a sort of
Gaussian function so it decreases like
this right that's not what happens in an
optical blur my lens blur so if we
remember back a while ago we did a
light-filled video you've got a point
light source here which is something in
your scene a person a light they've tree
not important right it's gonna be quite
a few of these if they if your image has
more than one pixel in it you have a
lens right which looks like this it
might have other glass optical elements
and you have an imaging plane here like
this and what happens is point light
don't just travel directly into your
camera everything just emits light in
lots of directions depending on its
properties so it comes in like this and
when it's in focus it will come and it
will hit a point on here and that pixel
will obtain that color the color will be
the sum of all of these light rays and
then it sort of simplified to be usually
between nought and 255 if you're out of
focus what will happen is these light
rays will come pass the camera like this
and focus on a point behind it and
actually you'll have this light will now
be spread over this whole area from the
front if this is the front of our square
sensor every point will now be a circle
like this
and each other point will also be a
circle and another circle in another
circle and this gets you that kind of
characteristic Lens Blur that you see
when something like light sources
christmas tree lights or something are
out of focus cut to a nice shot of this
so people spend a lot of money on lenses
primarily I think because of the quality
of this kind of blur they're not perfect
circles all the time sometimes there's
slightly odd all their hexagons because
you've got an aperture and things like
this they give this blurry sort of
unique characteristic even down to a
lens which you can't really get on a
computer but we can have a go because
we've got to do it at 60 frames a second
you haven't got the option of thinking
about Zeiss and like although this is
most obvious when you're looking at
point light actually this applies to any
blur right if you do a Gaussian blow of
a scene that doesn't have very bright
bits it will still look a bit different
than if you have a normal bouquet blur
right and and actually you look much
better if you do it properly can we
recreate our separable filters but now
perform a lens blur or at least an
approximation to a lens blur and the
answer is not it's not so easy but you
can kind of have a go you have to start
looking at imaginary numbers a little
bit but if we just sort of not worry
about it too much you essentially
replace your separable convolutions with
two complex separable convolutions and
we can start to start to get something
going so one particular game engine that
does this is EA's Frostbite engine which
drives a lot of its sports games so
things like Madden will have a nice blur
on certain shots that's created by an
artificial lens blur not a Gaussian blur
other games might kind of fake it a bit
of a Gaussian I don't know Primavera
folks it's not technically correct
there's a kind of short paper on this
there's a few blogs online that talk
about stepper lens blur there's some
implementations out there I've got my
own implementation that I wrote which
I'll release at the end of this video
there was a nice presentation at the
Game Developers Conference in 2017
showing office technology right so this
is real-time bouquet blur not Gaussian
blur right so how does it work well the
idea is that what we want to do is
instead of having our kernel which is
sort of like this and a Gaussian we need
to have it be a circle right in an ideal
world that right which from the top
looks like a nice cut clear-cut circle
now you can do that but you can't
separate it you can have a kernel which
is jazz
a load of zeros and then a circle of
ones in the middle and that will produce
you a very nice filter but it will take
ages because you have to do all this
point wise and it's not separable so
what we need to do is find a function
that we can split into a vertical pass
and a horizontal pass all right let's
look at example right one of the nice
things about Gaussian is but it's
separable right it's a naturally
separable function so how can we convert
a Gaussian to something that kind of
approximates this circular shape and the
answer is that we can sort of add in an
imaginary component and create sort of
complex Gaussian now obviously we're not
gonna go into huge amount of detail on
complex numbers but they have an
imaginary and a real component the
imaginary component is multiplied by I
which is a square root of minus 1 the
good news for us is that most of the
time when we actually need to use it the
eyes get multiplied out and they'd a
sort disappear or become a minus number
all right that's all buddy time gonna go
into actually it's a bit like when we
talked about our discrete cosine
transform and when maybe some time we'll
talk about Fourier transforms we have
waves that add together to create
something the shape we want in this case
the wave is going to be a Gaussian right
but it's going to go up and down like
this so instead of our Gaussian going
like this which is not quite centered
what we're going to roll on it we have
one that goes up and down right in the
complex the complex component of this
Gaussian is the bit that makes it do
that so we have a Gaussian that sort of
goes down like this and sort of centers
around here and it comes down like this
all right it's symmetrical and then we
have another one but perhaps come sort
of like this and when you add them
together you get the thing we want so
these kind of cancel out and you sort of
get some of looks a bit like this with a
bit of wobbling around and then it comes
up about here and then kind of goes like
that and then down like that right and
that is our circle and that is also
separable because it's essentially got a
Gaussian as it's sort of primary
function so I've coded this up and I've
been using it to mess around with
different blurs most of the code is to
do with creating the kernels I do some
normalization and things like this then
I pass the image from each component and
the very end I combine them Mayon I'll
draw a little diagram to show how that
works the more components you use a bit
like in JPEG or any kind of sort of
adding of waves the more ways you use
the better approximation you're going to
get right so if you're not watching it
for a game engine you can
use maybe two each time you do this
you've got quite a few convolutions you
can have to do these are complex
multiplication operations in addition it
takes time even on a graphics card right
and bear in mind there's other game
things to do right the game isn't static
with just this nice blur so you've got
other stuff to be worrying about fact
that there's an imaginary number
involved in some sense to me anyway
personally I like to look at it it's
basically not making any difference at
all the only difference is but the
addition and multiplication that you
would normally do in a convolution is
now a complex addition and a complex
multiplication which are sort of well
defined structures that you can just
apply and this is a mathematical term
not just as saying it's different it's
absolutely a mathematical term right and
it's actually not very complicated you
have your image right we have our first
component C naught here and we have
another component so you want we could
have lots of errs this has a complex
kernel so that we'll have a real and
imaginary right but they're just going
to look a bit like gaussians like I
showed you this is going to be the same
over here these are different ones and
the idea is that when we add these two
together we get a very nice disk so what
we're going to do is we're going to
converge with these and we're going to
converse in which with these and we're
going to add them together at the end
because I see a lot of addition goes on
all right so we take our image we go
through here and we get another image
out which is our real and another image
out which is our imaginary we go through
here we get an image out that's real and
image out that's an imaginary and then
we add these two together in a weighted
sum and then we take our fine or
weighted images for each component and
we add them together in our final output
like that the reason we have to do these
separately is so that we can make it
separable right this is this can be done
separately this can be done in the same
way very very quickly right if you're
doing it for just two components there's
a few convolutions you have to do add it
all together and you have your result
the SEPA bility means that instead of
doing all the kernel for every location
we do a vertical pass of a strip and we
take that output and put it through a
horizontal pass and then we combine the
outputs at the end and that's that's it
mathematically equivalent to doing the
2d version but much much faster so let's
have a look at some outputs right now
I've written some code here very
straightforward that essentially
produces these complex kernels in one
dimension and kind of
higher than 10 image you know in the
correct order add them up at the end so
we can blur smooches you know I'll
release the code so you can have a look
the original post that led me to this
work outlined a few parameters for these
kernels that butt looks good
right they heat optimized so I put them
in as well so let's have a look a couple
of these kernels and see what they are
so if I just look at the zero the one
component pass right so this is if you
want to try and create a disc with just
one of these complex kernels like what
would it look like well let's have a
look these are the real and imaginary
parts of this particular component and
this is going to look roughly like a
disc when we add these two together
let's see so if I take the two together
we can run it and it's kind of a
doughnut he disc right and the reason is
because you can't get a perfect disc
with just a real and imaginary part
added together it's not going to work so
what we can do is we can take another
kernel add that to it and now we've got
kind of two wheels and two imaginaries
in some loose sense add these all
together and maybe we can start to
approximate this disc so we'll get a
little bit better if I change this and
run that together all right so now it's
got a bit of a ripple to it but this is
starting to look quite a lot better like
this looks to me quite a lot like the
disc I'm hoping for and this is still
separable so I can take a strip from the
middle with a strip here and I can run
it in two passes and save a huge amount
of time because this is a sort of a this
is I think a 64 or 65 by 65 pixel kernel
this will be a big deal if you wanted to
run this over an image especially you
know a sort of resolution of modern
games run out so we can get even better
we can add more and more components so
if I've ramped up the number of
components like we get somebody looks
really really quite good there we go
so this now looks I think quite a lot
like a disc so essentially this is
equivalent to running a circle of ones
in a convolution over an image it's just
that now we can do it in these separable
components and save ourselves a huge
amount of time it's not perfect right
the size is difficult to manage the edge
is not as sharp as I'd like this should
be a sharp edge but you can't get an
absolutely sharp edge but for a sort of
game engine something in the background
it's gonna look great and it's going to
run really really quick in the EA and in
the Frostbite engine they'll only use
two components so it won't be a perfect
colonel but it will look pretty good
stars are a classic example of some
where we can use this blur because of
course their point lights have a nice
spread out nicely so this is what
happens if we Gaussian blur this image
it looks dull and light just like not
high-resolution and doesn't look great
right if we if we look at the lens
version I mean I think it's
aesthetically better right when it looks
like this right each of these points has
spread out into a nice disc I've had to
do some exposure here because it's
that's difficult to do but I think it
looks pretty good so that's the Gaussian
and that is the lens blur I think that
looks a lot better so this is our fake
lens blur by using our our circular disc
kernel with lots of components because I
wasn't worried about speed right even if
you did it with two components we still
look good so if you were running this in
a game what you would do is you would
start to separate out the foreground and
the background of a scene you'd blur
anything you wanted to not be in focus
and keep anything you did want to be in
focus sharp and then you'd start to
bring them all together at the end by
you know alpha blending or overlaying so
you sent me a picture of some Lego so
we've got a lego man here on a table
with some lights in a jar behind right
so this is quite a good example of
something we could try this out on so
you also thankfully gave me some
foreground and background masks for this
so I blurred the background and I
blended in the foreground as you might
do in a game but love and encode it I
kind of hacked it together in paint but
I think it looks really good so so this
is our Gaussian attempt so here
I've essentially taken the man away I've
blurred at this using a Gaussian and I
put the man back in basically and he
looks okay but if we flip to the lens
blur I think it looks a lot better right
it looks a lot more like a true sort of
bouquet blur you might expect from a
lens and so this is exactly what you'll
see when you play FIFA and when you play
PGA Tour and when you play Madden and
any of these sports titles when it cuts
to a kind of nice depth of field shot
let let's say means instant replay this
will be at work behind the scenes
there's loads of different tricks it's
just one of them I think this is really
interesting because apart from the fact
that I think this is quite
mathematically elegant right not
everyone will agree I just think it's
cooler in these games and in you know
they're doing all these little tips and
tricks to make it run at 60 frames
but still look really good and you don't
notice like you know what no one really
knows until you read up on it that
Madden has a different depth of field
approach to some other games but maybe
you just liked that a little bit better
you didn't know and that's one of the
things you liked about that game and I
just think that's really cool that you
know these things are going on behind
the scenes so we don't know they exist
but they just make it a little bit
better what you think right so in this
case it's going through glass the glass
is moving things around that is going to
be lost a little bit in our in our blur
another thing is about our disk is not
absolutely sharp right and we can't
approximate hexagons with it so you
can't do that kind of blur but I think
the main problem is that the exposure is
very hard to get